Jeder hat sie und irgendwie kommt man auch nicht drum herum die guten alten
weihnachtstraditionen für manche ist es der gefüllte gänsebraten mit rotkohl und klößen nämlich fehlen darf für andere ist es der serien marathon nach der
bestellung aber nicht nur auf weiten teilen dieser
Welt wird weihnachten gefeiert sondern auch in welt als zum beispiel auf der internationalen raumstation iss
oder woanders wird woanders opfer ich weiß nicht ob die besatzung einen tannenbaum geschmückt
Wie genau die bescherung dort aussieht und was star wars mit den festtagen im weltraum zu tun hat jetzt in science fiction mit unserer
sonderedition zu weihnachten herzlich willkommen also und frohe weihnachten
Ja mitte dezember haben sich drei neuen raumfahrer zur iss auf gemacht quasi driving home for christmas in gewisser
weise oder driving home for christmas die sojus rakete mit den amerikanischen astronauten scott kinkel und
Neuschnee kann und dem kosmonauten anton stapel leerer war am letzten sonntag vom russischen weltraumbahnhof baikonur in kasachstan
Gestartet als möglicher ersatzmann war übrigens der deutsche alexander gerst am start
Am dienstag hat die soli sms 07 dann an der iss angedockt heißt also weihnachten
Und silvester auf da ss und tatsächlich würde sind 400 kilometern. Höhe richtig weihnachtlich laut einer russischen agentur meldung gibt es tatsächlich
einen tannenbaum eine russische zeitung schreibt dass der sogar dauerhaft auf der iss eingelagert ist macht ja auch in gewisser weise sind
schließlich wiederholt sich weihnachten in regelmäßigen abständen auch wenn es immer überraschen kommt aber sogar ein zweiter baum ist wohl in planung und soll
Doch schon mit einem us raumtransporter zur iss
Gelangt sein fehlen also nur noch die geschenke für eine feierliche bescherung und die wird wohl ein russischer frachter zur iss bringen
Sowohl von den familien des teams als auch von roskosmos und der nasa und jetzt noch
zu einem sehr wichtigen bestandteil von weihnachten dem essen
Selbst das weihnachtsfest wird nichts daran ändern dass es das menü
Aus alufolie und konserven gibt was konkret aufgetischt wird ist noch nicht bekannt in den letzten jahren gab es so was wie
truthahn grüne bohnen kartoffeln
schokoladenkuchen und fruchtsalat fest steht jedenfalls
Die astronauten werden achtung jetzt kommt den neuen star wars film auf der iss sehen dürfen
Ja der plan der nasa der film wird über das space center in texas zwei ss hochgeladen
da
Wär ich echt gern dabei und es werden die tradition aus allen teilen der welt mit eingebracht in den bevorstehenden feiertagen
Denn es sind ja neben den drei us amerikaner und in dem japaner auch noch zwei russische besatzungsmitglieder
Am start und das orthodoxe weihnachtsfest am 7 januar
gefeiert früher gab es dazu dann schon einmal eine botschaft eines moskauer
patriarchen an die crew so oder so es wird jedenfalls festlich in den letzten jahren gab es auch immer mal wieder ziemlich kitschige weihnachtsdeko
In 400 kilometern. Höhe das zeigen beweisfotos der cruze und im hintergrund weihnachts strümpfe lametta und rote santa clause mützen
2012 hatte der kanadische astronaut chris redfield sogar seine gitarre dabei und dann steht ja noch silvester an
Wann feiern die das eigentlich und wie oft hallo wer kann das recherchieren und in die kommentare schreiben?
auf jeden fall wird auch auf der iss angestoßen neben den ganzen partys gibt es aber auch eine menge zu tun
auf dem programm für nächstes jahr stehen mehr als 250 experimente und zwar in sachen technik medizin und biologie
Anfang, des neuen jahres wird dann. Zudem wird es verschiedene außeneinsätze
Geben tja und wenn er davon nichts verpassen wollt dann sollten wir hier ein abo aufsaugen vergessen ich dem
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Sonneneruptionen bedrohen die iss also ansonsten bis dann
Bleibt dran vor weihnachten und so weiter und so fort und bleibt friedlich